ก็
สวัสดีค่ะพี่เอ๋สวัสดีค่ะโคเรียมสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียน
ผู้เอเอเค้าวันนี้เราเจอกันเป็นวันอะไรคะ
วันอาทิตย์ค่ะ
วันอาทิตย์ใช่วันอาทิตย์วันจันทร์
ทุกทีก็เอกกันนัดโคเรียมวันอาทิตย์ใช่ตอน
นี้อบนี้อยู่ที่แล้ววันจันทร์ค่ะวัน
จันทร์วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 16 ค่ะ 6
เดือนอะไรคะเดือนพฤษภาคมค่ะ
พฤษภาคมปีพตอะไรคะ
2565 ค่ะ
ที่แล้วปีคศอะไรค่ะ
2022 ค่ะ
2022 ตอนนี้กี่โมงแล้วคะครูเอ๋อ่าอันนี้
ล่ะครับ
8:00 น 28 นาทีนโมง 28
วันนี้เราตื่นแต่เช้ามากเลยค่ะเก๋ไอสองคน
ตื่นเช้ามากแต่ว่ายังไม่ได้กินข้าว
ใช่ท้องร้องนิดหน่อยจอ
หิวหิวหิวๆๆหิวข้าวแล้ว
หิวมากๆดีไหมคะโคเรียวหิวมากๆก็ไม่ดีนะคะ
ตัวเองไม่ดีใช่ไหมใช่ไม่ดีแล้วครูเรีย
เวลาหิวมากๆไม่ได้กินข้าว
พูดหงิดไหมคะ
หงุดหงิดมากๆมันตอนนี้แหละค่ะครูเอ๋เรียน
กำลังที่สุด
ใช่เพราะว่าเวลาเราตื่นมัน
หิวข้าวอ่ะมีบุตรหงิดเมื่อไหร่จะสอน 7
อย่างนี้เขาบอกว่าอะไรจะเสร็จเมื่อไหร่จะ
ได้กินข้าว
ให้ดูจริงจังเนาะดูเหมือนจริงจังทำไมเรา
ถึงพูดเรื่องคิวข้าวแล้วหงุดหงิดเขาคู่
เตรียม
ตัวเอกก็เห็นรู้ไหมว่าเวลาที่คนคิวมากๆ
ฆ่าคนตายได้เลยนะอ๋ออ๋อคุณโอเคคุณเรียนจะ
เบรคไปกินข้าวก่อนนะคะ
คู่เอกกูเอกกลัวกลัวกลัวเรียมหิวข้าวแล้ว
ก็
ฆ่ากู
ไม่เป็นไรค่ะครูเอกอยู่ไกลอยู่กูอายุไกล
มากตอนนี้เดี๋ยวก็เรียนทุบทุบของมากเรียง
มีน้ำไหมคะดื่มน้ำก่อนดื่มแล้วค่ะมีน้ำ
อ่ะ
[เพลง]
ขอน้ำองุ่นค่ะคุณเอ๋ขอน้ำดื่มน้ำก่อนนะ
ครับทุเรียนดื่มน้ำก่อน
ใจเย็นๆใจเย็นๆนะคะใจเย็นๆคนน่ะไม่กิน
ข้าวได้นาน 21 วันไม่ตาย
ก็แบบแบนต้องดื่มน้ำนะคะดื่มน้ำโพเรียมใจ
เย็นใจเย็นอย่าอย่าเพิ่งค่า
ส่งใหม่ทำไมคุณเรียนบอกว่าหิวลดค่าได้
รู้ไหมว่ามีคนที่หิวมากๆหรอกค่ะคนตายจริง
ๆของประเทศไทย
อันนี้เป็นเรื่องจริงหรือเรื่องเรื่อง
เล่าค่ะเป็นเรื่องจริงค่ะเรื่องจริงอัน
นี้เรื่องจริงเลยหรอใช่เกิดขึ้นเมื่อไหร่
คะเกิดขึ้นที่ประมาณปีพตต 2010
[เพลง]
a330
ครูเอกยังไม่เกิด
เตรียมก็ยังไม่เกิด
2330 นี่ปีนี้ปีอะไรนะปีนี้
คืนกี่ปีมาแล้วคะประมาณ 200
230  5 ปีใช่ไหมใช่
235 ปีที่แล้ว
[เพลง]
235 ปีที่แล้วแบบนี้
อะมีหลักฐานไหมคะ
นี่มีค่ะตำนานเป็นตำนานหรือเป็นเรื่อง
จริง
หรออ๋อคือหรือว่าเล่นเชื่อว่าเป็นเรื่อง
จริงมันก็เลยแบบเป็นเรื่องตัวเองก็เป็น
ครับเลี้ยงกูไปเองก็ไม่รู้ว่าที่จริงหรือ
ว่าตำนานเพราะว่าตอนตอนครูเอ๋เรื่องที่
ครูเรียมกำลังจะพูดเนี่ยเวลาคู๋เด็กๆ
เนี่ยอาบพ่อบอกว่าพ่อมีตำนานเล่าให้ฟัง
ตำนานคือเป็นเรื่องเล่าใช่มะเล่ามาเล่าๆ
มันเหมือนนิทานนะคะอย่างนิดของนักเรียนจะ
มีนิทานเรื่อง Cinderella  Snow  White
อันนี้เป็นนิทานไม่จริงใช่ไหมคะเป็น
เรื่องไม่จริงแต่ว่าตำนานเนี่ยเขาบอกมัน
ก็
50% จริงอ่ะใช่ไหมคะอาจจะ 50%
50% ไม่จริง
ผู้เตรียมคือเรื่องนะเกิดทางภาคอีสานของ
ไทยบาทของไทยทางโน้นก็บอกว่าเรื่องจริง
อ่ะจากครูเอ๋อยู่ภาคกลางเอกตำนาน
มาถึงเล่นจริง
อันนี้คือประเทศไทยใช่ไหมคะ
เหมือนประเทศไทยเราปากๆนะ
ประเทศไทย
เนี่ย
จะมีพระธาตุพระธาตุก่องข้าวน้อยอยู่ที่ 5
เรียกว่าเรียกว่าพระธาตุค่ะใช่อยู่
จังหวัดอะไรคะอยู่ที่จังหวัดยโสธร
ยโสธรอยู่ภาคอีสานของประเทศไทยค่ะแล้วภาค
ตะวันออกอยู่ตรงไหนคะเนี่ยข้างตะวันออก
เหนือใต้อยู่แถวนี้หรือเปล่า
กูเรียนต้องต่อภาคตะวันออกแหลมลงมาให้
หน่อยใช่ไหมอย่างนี้ล่ะคะ
ตะวันออก
เรื่องว่ายังไงคะและเตรียมเรื่องนี้ค่ะมี
แม่อยู่คนนึงค่ะมีแม่
เราก็ในครอบครัวเราก็จะมีแม่มีพ่อใช่ไหม
คะแต่ว่าพ่อของครอบครัวนี้เขาตายไปแล้ว
อ๋อแล้วก็มีลูกไหมคะเขามีลูกเป็นลูกชาย
ค่ะลูกชายสองคนค่ะสองคนทั้งปี
คุณแม่เนี่ยคือชื่อคุณแม่สา
อ๋อมีชื่อด้วยชายลืมก็เลยเชื่อมั้ยคะว่า
เป็นเรื่องจริง
กูเอกก็ไม่รู้นะเราฟังไปก่อนค่ะหน้าคลิป
ร้องคลิปนี้จะจริงไม่จริงใช่มะก็ไม่รู้
เดี๋ยวนักเรียนก็ฟังก่อนนะเพราะว่า
235 ปีที่แล้วนะคะใช่ค่ะเย้คุณอาสนามี
รูปสองคนนะลูกเขามีชื่อไหมคะมีค่ะลูกคน
ที่หนึ่งอ้ะชื่อบุญชื่ออะไรคะชื่ออะไรนะ
บุญตา
ลุกคนที่สองชื่อ
ลูกคนที่ชอบ 2 ชื่อทองมา
[เพลง]
วิธีดีค่ะ
ใช่แต่ว่าลูกคนที่ 1 เนี่ยเหมือนคู่เอกกะ
ทั้งค่ะอ๋อเจอถามว่าครอบครัวนี้ทำอาชีพ
อะไร
อ๋อครอบครัวนี้นะคะทำนายค่ะ
ทำนาปลูกข้าว
สุกข้าวที่เรากินข้าวกันนะคะคุยค่ะแต่ว่า
ว่าลูกคนที่ 1 เขาไม่ได้ทำนานนะคะทำอะไร
ค่ะเขาบวชบวชเป็นพระที่อยู่ที่วัดโงกเป็น
คนดีไหม
ลูกคนที่ 2 อ่ะลูกคนที่สองก็ทำนายค่ะ
สัมนาก็เป็นคนดีเหมือนกันนะเอ้าทำนายทำ
ปลูกข้าวให้คุณแม่กิน
ใช่แล้วท้องจริงร้านทั้งสองคนนะเฮ้ยค่ะ
เขาเป็นคนที่ดีมากๆทั้งสองคนค่ะแล้วทองมา
ก็รักแม่มากๆนะรักแม่มากเลยค่ะ
แต่งงานไหม
เตรียมไม่ได้เห็นว่าเขาแต่งงานไม่ไม่มี
ใครพูดถึง
อัยยุเนื้อยังไม่ถึงเนาะยังไม่ถึงแต่งงาน
แต่ขยันนะขยันทำงานนะคะขยันไปทำงานตื่น
เช้าขึ้นมาก็มาที่ทุ่งนามาทำนายนี้ในทุกๆ
วันค่ะครูเอ๋ค่ะตื่นทำนายนี้ต้องตื่นกี่
โมงคะเนี่ยน่าจะ 5:00 นใช่ค่ะประมาณ 5:00
น 4 ปี 4 กว่าๆเตรียมของเจมส์อะไรตี 5 ก็
ออกไปนะคะ
ใช่ค่ะก็ออกไปเพราะว่าทำนายนักเรียนไม่ไป
ตอนเที่ยงนะร้อน
ก็จะออกไปยังเวลาไปทำนาเนี่ยออกไปทำนาย
ได้กินข้าวหรือยังคะยังถ้ากูเองยังไม่ได้
ยิน
เหมือนๆคู่เรียมกับครูเอ๋คือยังไม่ได้กิน
ข้าวนะคะๆยังไม่ได้กินข้าวก็คุณทองมาคุณ
เลยนะฮะก็จะออกไปทำนายจากทำนายไปก็ทำเช้า
ๆมันไม่ร้อนอ่ะถ้าไม่ร้อนก็ทำงานได้เยอะๆ
นะฮะเธอแล้วประมาณใสๆเนาะซักประมาณ 07:00
น 08:00 น
08:00 นแม่ก็จะเอาอาหารไปให้ใช่ไหมคะใช่
ค่ะฟิกูได้
เองก็เคยได้ยินใช่ไหมคะเวลาเรียนค่ะตอน
เด็กๆ
คุณพ่อเล่าให้ฟังคุณครูสอนนะคะเป็นเรื่อง
ที่ต้องเรียนบางทีพระก็สอนนะคะก็คุณแม่
เอาอาหารไปให้กินทุกวันโอ้ยยยยดีมั้ยดี
มากๆค่ะครูเอ๋เพราะว่าคุณทองมาเนี่ยเขาจะ
ได้ไปทำงานทำงานตั้งแต่เช้าแล้วก็จะได้
แบบ
ปลูกข้าวปลูกข้าวเสร็จเยอะๆเขาแม่ก็จะ
หิ้วมีคิวอะไรนะใหญ่อะไรได้ไม่อะไร
เรียกว่าอะไรค่ะ
ภาษาไทยกลางเรียกว่ากระติ
แต่ว่าใครเรียกว่าอะไรคะอีสานเรียกว่า
กล่องข้าวอ๋อ
กะปิ๊กไม่ใช่ภาษาอีสานน่ะ
ครั้งนี้ศาลเรียกกล่องข้าวนะคะเรียงเห็น
คนที่อยู่ไทยกลางพูดกระติกกระติกกระติ๊บ
แต่คนอีสานแยกกล่องข้าว
อ๋อไม่เพราะครูเอ๋คู๋ในได้ยินจากคนอีสาน
ที่ทำงานเขาเรียกกันติ๊บ
เออตัวเอก
เออ
ไม่รู้กล่องข้าวก็ได้กระปิปก็ได้นะคะแต่
ว่า
กะโต๊ะใบทีก็กล่องข้าวบางทีก็กระติ๊บ
โอเคเนาะคะใช่ค่ะก็คืออันเดียวกันก็คือ
อันนี้
ทีนี้นะ
กระติ๊บกระติ๊บก็มีทั้งเล็กๆแล้วก็เล็กๆ
แล้วก็ใหญ่ๆใช่อยากจะ
ใส่ข้าวเหนียวปิดมีฝาปิดปิดแล้วข้าวก็จะ
ร้อนร้อนอยู่ข้างในใช่ติด
ใช่แล้วคุณแม่เอาข้าวใส่ใส่อันนี้ใส่
กระติ๊บแล้วก็อาหารนะคะกับข้าว
กับข้าวคุณแม่ก็เอาใส่เหมือนปิ่นโตนะใส่
ปิ่นโต
เดี๋ยวคุณลืมโคเรียม 200  200  230  5 ปี
ที่ไม่มีเธอไม่มีปิดเป็นใบไม้
ขออาจจะเป็นไก่ไก่ย่างปลาย่างเราก็ใส่ใบ
ไม้ดีหรือใส่ประชามีอาจจะใส่ชามก็ได้แล้ว
ก็ไปนะคะใช่ค่ะไม่เหมือนเรานะคะครูเอง
เรียนแล้วตื่นมาตอนเช้าแล้วหิวข้าวก็กิน
ข้าวเลยแต่ว่าคุณจะไม่ต้องทำอาหารนะคะ
เรียงก็ลืมตื่นล่ะค่ะนั่นแหละ
มันมีอาหารอยู่แล้วพ่อแม่เลี้ยงมาชอบทำ
อาหาร
ค่ะแล้วเวลาที่เรียนอยู่บ้านกับแม่เรียม
ตื่นมาก็แม่ทำกับข้าวเสร็จแล้วนี้ก็กิน
กินเขียวไม่คนโชคดีไว้เหมือนกูเองกูเอง
ตื่นมาต้องทำอาหารให้หาให้คนที่บ้านคนที่
บ้านตื่นมาก็มีอาหาร
แอบน่ารักมากน่ารักเหมือนแม่เรียมเลยที่
ตัวเองไม่อยากนอนตื่นอาหารอ่ะเอ้อใช่แต่
ว่าสมัยก่อนนะคะนักเรียนสมัยก่อนไม่ง่าย
สมัยนี้นะอ่าถ้าคนทำอาหารเหนื่อยก็เดิน
เดินไปแล้วก็ซื้ออาหารกลับมาแล้วก็เทได้
นะคะหรือโทรศัพท์ก็ได้ใช่ไหมคะตอนนี้นะมี
อาหารขายมากๆในสมัยก่อนคุณแม่สารเนี่ยอ่า
เขาจะต้องทำอาหารเนี่ยต้องจุดไฟใช่ไหมใช่
จุดไฟตั้งแต่เช้าหาดูว่าไฟเขาเขามีเตา
แก๊สไม่มีค่ะ
จุดไฟรถทำอาหารเค้าใช้อะไรคะจดไปเนี่ยหนู
ยังไม่รู้ค่ะครูเอง
ของน้อยเท่าไหร่นะ 200 บาท
เราใช้เตาฟื้นรู้หรอ
เหรียญเหรียญ 10 คูณเรียนครูเหตุตีหัว
เรียมได้มั้ยฮะ
จากเตาเดี๋ยว
เออ
รู้จักเออนั่นแหละ
แล้วก็มีก้อนหินสามก้อนแล้วก็มีก้อนหิน
อ่ะคมเฉพาะฮิตน่ะผู้เรียนผู้เรียน
เดี๋ยวกูเอา Share  screen อยู่นะกูอีก
ว่าได้
มาเดี๋ยว
สกรีนผู้ a  The นะ
อ้าโอเคจะเป็นแบบนี้นะคะนักเรียนถ้าเป็น
สมัยก่อนนะเขาจะมีก้อนหินแบบนี้ค่ะ
ก็มีไม้แบบนี้
ราซะก์จุดไฟตรงนี้อ่ะ
การทำอาหาร
ทรายแล้วก็อ่ะเขาจะมีหม้อหม้อจะเป็นสีน้ำ
ตาลเนาะก็จะเป็นหม้อแบบนี้
ทำไมก่อนหน้าจะเป็นหม้อแบบนี้มั้ง
หม้อดิน
แล้วก็ถ้านึ่งข้าวเหนียวเนาะข้าวเหนียว
เขาก็จะต้องมี
นี่แหละ
เราเรียกว่าหวด
ขวด
อันนี้จะทำจากไม้ไผ่
อันนี้เป็นต้นไผ่นะคะค่ะ
ต้นไผ่แล้วก็อันเนี้ยอ้าวมาทำหวดก็จะลงไป
ตรงนี้
ไปนี้ก็จะมีน้ำ
สาขาตรงนี้ก็มีไฟ
อะตรงนี้ก็จะปิดฝานะคะอ่ะกิน
ข้าวข้าวจะอยู่ข้างในล่ะข้าวแล้วก็หนึ่ง
เอาแบบนี้เรียกว่าสามเศร้ารักสามเศร้าแต่
ว่าขอโทษถ้าไม่ใช่ตับไว้
ถ้าไม่ใช่เต่าแบบนี้ก็จะเป็นเตาเตาแบบแบบ
นี้ก็ได้ค่ะ
เป็นเต่าแบบนี้
เอาแบบนี้ก็จะใส่ใส่ไม้ตรงนี้ก็ได้ก็มีไฟ
ที่นี่
ก็ได้
เอาแบบนี้เต่าอะไรเข้าเตาเตาอังโล่
[เพลง]
อันนี้อันนี้ตวังโลกนะคะอันนี้เต่าสาม
เส้าตรงนี้ค่ะก้อนหินนะเอา
อันนี้ 3 นักเรียนมองเห็นเนี่ยมีก้อนหิน
สามก้อนมาก็เรียกว่าสามเส้านะครับ
1-3 เรียนรู้จักเขมรตัดรู้จักเตาอังโล่
ค่ะแล้วก็รู้จักเตาแก๊ส
รู้จักเตาแก๊สกูเรียนอายุ 29 นะคะวัยรุ่น
ไว้
ไวโบราณวรต่างแต่กู a หน้าถุงข้าวสาม
เศร้าได้อั้งโล่ได้ไม่มีเตาคูเอกหุงข้าว
ได้
ถึงไม่กินเต่ากูได้นะครูเรียมคู่เอกก็ทำ
แบบนี้
อันนี้เป็นดินใช่ไหมคะเป็นดินรึเราก็เข้า
มาขุดแล้วก็องค์ข้าวได้หนู
กลับมาเรื่องของเราดีกว่าโอเคของเราดี
กว่าพูดเอ๋
ที่นี้มันอยู่นะให้ก็ปกติค่ะคุณคุณอะไรนะ
บุญทองมา
ทองมาใช่ไหมคะเขาจะไปปลูกข้าว
ของว่าหมายผูก
เตรียมเล่าไปแล้วใช่ไหมคะครูเอ๋ว่าแม่สา
กับทองมาน่ะเค้ารักกันมากๆเราแม่สาเขารู้
ได้ว่าคุณทองมาเนี่ยชอบกินอะไร
เขาก็ตั้งใจทำกับข้าวทำกับข้าวให้อร่อย
ที่สุดให้ลูกชายสุขมีความสุขทุกวันๆ
แต่ว่ามีวันนึงค่ะอ่ะ The  One  The กะทะ
เป็นวันพระด้วยนะคะครูเอ๋
เมื่อวานไงใช่เหมือนเมื่อวานที่เป็นวัน
พระค่ะคุณแม่สารเนี่ยเขาก็จะทำกับข้าว
แต่ว่าทุกๆวันเนี่ยเขาก็จะเอากับข้าวไป
ให้คองมาตอนประมาณ
07:00 น 08:00 นใช่ไหมคะค่ะแต่เวลาวัน
พระเขาจะทำกับข้าวไปที่วัดเกาะน
[เพลง]
ให้ไปทำบุญที่วัดที่บุญทาเป็นพระอยู่ใช่
ค่ะเพราะว่าคนใครจะเข้าวัดวันพระนะวรรณ
รักน่าจะเข้าให้
นั่นแหละแล้วเลยน่ะ
แม่สายเหมือนเป็นพูดไม่
ใช่คือจริงๆก็เป็นแบบนี้บ่อยๆใช่ไหมคะทุก
ๆทุกๆอ้ะวันชนะต้องไปวัดใช่ๆแต่ว่ามีอยู่
วันหนึ่งที่เกิดเรื่องเนี่ยทำไมค่ะเกิด
เรื่องก็คือไปวัดแล้วมาหาคลองมาเนี่ยซ้าย
มากๆที่ว่าวันนั้นแม่สาไม่ค่อยสบายด้วย
ใช่ป่ะใช่ไหม
เพราะว่าเพราะว่าบุญทานก็เป็นพระนานๆแล้ว
ใช่ไหมคะช่อไปวัดมาหาลูกชนะที่นาแต่วัน
นั้นน่าจะแบบขาแข้งไม่ค่อยดีนะคะหมอแก่
เดินแก่เดินช้าลงเมื่อก่อนเป็นชาวนา
เหมือนกันเจ็บหลังอะไรแบบนี้
พอแม่สากลับไปบ้านก็จากวัดไปบ้านก็ต้อง
เตรียมอาหารทางมาให้ทองมาใช่ไหมคะแต่ตอน
นั้นมันกี่โมงแล้วคะครูเรียมวุ้กี่โมงอ่ะ
สาย 10 โมงได้เปล่าครับพี่เอ๋
ถึงบ้านน่าจะประมาณสัก 9 โมงกว่าๆแล้ว
9 โมงกว่าๆขึ้นแล้วบอกว่าสายๆตอนนั้นไม่
มีนาฬิกาเราก็บอกสายคือร้อนแล้วรอส
แล้วก็ทองมาเป็นยังไงคะตอนนั้นเขามาก็ครู
ข้าวแล้วก็ไม่เหนื่อยมากเหนื่อยแล้วก็หิว
ข้าว
อยู่ข้าว
มองหาแม่แม่ไม่มาใช่ไหมค่ะใช่
แม่ไม่มาแล้วก็รู้สึกยังไงคะพูดเอ๋เวลาคน
เราหิวข้าวก็มาก
โอ๊ยทำไมทำงานทำงานไม่ได้คุยจะหาอะไรแถว
นี้กินน่ะสิ
หมอเขาก็หาอะไร
ไปอยู่ทุ่งนาแล้วไม่เหมือนตอนนี้นะที่แบบ
คิวแล้วก็ซื้อกินได้เมื่อก่อนซื้อกินไม่
ได้ต้องรอคุยแล้วร้อง 5 อยู่
[เพลง]
แต่ว่าทองมานี่หิวหิวคุณแม่คุณแม่เป็นยัง
ไงครับรู้ว่าสายแล้วคุณแม่ทำอะไรเลี้ยง
คุณแม่ก็เตรียมกับข้าวมาแล้ว
เนี่ยกล่องข้าว
ใส่ข้าวเหนียวมาใส่ข้าวเหนียวมาเยอะๆ
มาให้นั้นกลายเปงกล่องข้าวเหมือนเดิมใช่
ไหมคะผงข้าวเหมือนเดิมของแต่มันมันกล่อง
ข้าวไม่น้อยนั่นแหละกล่องข้าวนะว่ากล่อง
เล็กๆกล่องเท่าเดิมกล่องเท่าเดิมแล้วคุณ
แม่ทำยังไงกับข้าวที่ใส่ลงไปคุณแม่ก็เอา
ข้าวเหนียวๆข้าวเหนียวใส่ลงไปเยอะๆแล้วก็
เขาเรียกว่าอ่ะไม่ใช่ๆอัดข้าวเหนียวไหม
คือคุณแม่แม่น่ะนักเรียนคุณไม่รู้ว่าลูก
กินเท่าไหร่แต่วันนี้เลยลูกจะหิวมากคุณ
แม่ก็คิดเดี๋ยวลูกไม่อิ่มคุณแม่ก็ใส่ข้าว
เหนียวเยอะๆจะเป็นกัดตีนกูอีกบอกแล้วมี
ไซส์ขนาดนี้ขนาดนี้ขนาดนี้แต่ว่าคุณ
กระติบอันเนี้ยเล็กๆแต่คุณแม่อ่ะค่ะอัด
แน่นๆเลยอ่ะแน่นเลยนะคะไม่กินได้ 2 มื้อ
อ่ะนานๆแล้วคุณแม่ก็รีบไปหาทองมาใช่ไหมคะ
ใช่ค่ะรีบมาหาทองมาของมาเห็นคุณแม่
ถึงกล่องข้าวมา
ยื้อต่อกล่องข้าวแหละเล็กมากคุณแม่วิ่งปะ
ลบมาด้วยน้องมากขอโทษขอโทษลูกอ่ะกินข้าว
อ่ะแกะออกมาเห็นกูเรียนเป็นทองมาเอาต้อง
มาข้าวลูก
ต้องข้าวเที่ยวมากๆนะทำไมตอกข้าวเล็กขนาด
นี้
มันไม่อิ่ม
ท้องมาทำอะไรอ่ะ
มาโมโหลงมากดมากเราทองมาก็เลย
สีแม่ใช่ไหมคะพี่เอ๋
กำลังเล่าอยู่นะ
เรื่องกำลังแล้วอยู่แต่ว่าอันที่เรียงฟัง
มาเนี่ยก็คือเขาเขาเขาตีแม่แต่เดิมก็ไม่
รู้นะว่าเมื่อ
233  35 ปีที่แล้วนะเขาออกอะไรตีแม่
อาจจะเป็น
ไอ้
เอ๋คิดว่าเป็นทีเวลาทำนามีควายมาหมอ
เขามีไอ้ที่อยู่ที่คอควาย
ก็จะมีมีอะไรที่อยู่ในนานแล้วค่ะถ้าอยู่
ในนาติอ่ะคือเขาก็โกรธคือนักเรียนคะเขา
เรียกว่าโมโหหิวคือเสียใจอ่ะแม่ทำไมอ่ะ
หนูผมหิวว่าจะไม่มีอาหารเยอะนี้ผมทำงาน
เหนื่อยทำไมแม่ไปคุยหิวมากเขาเรียกว่า
โมโหหิวทำไมแม่ไม่รักกับตีอ่ะแม่ก็ล้มไป
อ่ะคือเขาก็ได้ 7 วันน่ะไม่ได้เจ็บก็ไม่
ได้ข้างไงเขาหิวจนแบบนึกออกมั้ยคะนัก
เรียนคือเขาทำงานหนักมากมันเขาหิวหิวจน
ดับ
ตาลายอ่ะเออเพราะว่าเขาทำงานตั้งแต่ 5:00
น 5:00 น 5:00 หกโมงเช้า 07:00 น 08:00 น
09:00 น 10:00 นกี่ชั่วโมง 5 ที่เจ็ดแปด
เก้าสิบหกชั่วโมงแล้วก็ไม่ได้กินข้าวตั้ง
แต่เมื่อวานตอนเย็นเนาะกินข้าวเสร็จทำ
อะไรแล้วนอนตื่นมาทำงานอีก 6 ชั่วโมง 5  6
ชั่วโมงไม่ได้กินข้าวเพราะเห็นแม่เอาข้าว
มานิดหน่อยทำไมแม่ไม่รักผม
แล้วแม่ก็ล้มไปเขาก็ไม่สนใจนะคะแล้วเขาก็
มาเปิดกระติ๊บแล้วก็ไปไหนคะพี่เปิด Stitch
แล้วก็กินข้าวค่ะคุณเอ๋กินข้าว
กินไม่หมดค่ะกล่องข้าวเล็กๆแต่แม่ก็อัด
ข้าวเหนียวมาเยอะมากแล้วเขาก็กินไม่หมด
แล้วเขาก็เห็นกับข้าวที่แม่เอามาให้ก็
เป็นกับข้าวที่ชอบกิน
เขาก็เลยรู้แล้วรักเขามากๆ
อันนี้ก็อิ่มแล้วใช่ไหมคะอ่ะแต่ตอนนี้
อิ่มกินข้าวอิ่มแล้วกินแม่นแล้วอิ่มแล้ว
ข้าวไม่หมดอิ่มแล้วสบายใจหรือยังสบายใจ
แล้วค่ะครูเอ๋แต่ว่าสบายแล้วแล้วก็คูณ
เรียนบอกเขารู้ว่าแม่รักแล้วแล้วเขาหันไป
ดูแม่ไหมค่ะเขาก็เลยเอ้ย
เค้าตีแม่ไปแม่เขาก็สลบอยู่
ข้างๆก็เลยไปดูแม่
แต่ว่า
แม่เขาเป็นยังไงคะเกิดอะไรขึ้นตายแล้วค่ะ
ครูเอ๋
ตายแล้ว
แล้วนั้นต้องมาก็ต้องโดนตำรวจจากสิ
ใช่ไหมใช่
แต่ว่าตอนนั้นเขาก็เอาศพแม่เขาอ่ะ
จะเอาไปไหนเอาสุขแม่เขาแล้วก็มาทำเป็นแบบ
ที่เก็บ
ที่เก็บออกขอทำเป็นได้อะไรนะตรงนั้นเขา
เรียกว่าธาตุนะ
ค่ะถ้าเราไปฝัดหนังนะคะนักเรียนเอาไปฝัง
ทำพิธีศพแล้วก็ขอโทษนะคะอ่าเราก็ชาวบ้าน
ก็โอ้ทองมาไม่ดี
ทำไมฆ่าแม่ก็เลยเป็นเรื่องเล่าต่อๆกันมา
ว่าแต่กล่องเข้าน้อยเนี่ยกล่องเล็กๆเนี่ย
ฆ่าแม่เพราะว่าคิวมากเกินไปนะคะถ้าไงเวลา
เราไปยโสธรก็เลยต้องไปดูพระธาตุกล่องข้าว
น้อยฆ่าแม่คนภาคกลางก็ได้เรียนขนาดนี้ครู
เอ๋ตอนเด็กๆก็ได้เรียนก็เป็นการสอนว่าใจ
เย็นๆเวลาหิวคิวเราไม่โกรธคุณแม่น่ะรู้
ลูกจะกินอะไรลูกกินมากเท่าไหร่เห็นอ่ะ
เห็นอาหารนิดหน่อยอย่าเพิ่งโกรธเพราะท้อง
เราก็เท่าเนี้ยให้กินกินเสร็จก่อนอิ่มเรา
ค่อยคิดหาๆค่ะไปถึงว่าไม่ใช่ๆไม่โกรธโกรธ
เลยไม่ได้ให้ใจเย็นๆนะคะถ้าไม่อิ่มก็บอก
เดี๋ยวคุณแม่ก็เอามาให้เพิ่มนะคะใช่
เหมือนตอนนี้เรื่องก็ต้องใจเย็นๆเพราะว่า
เล่มก็หิวข้าวมากๆแต่ว่ากูเอกก็จะต้องไป
หาว่าหมดเวลาแล้วเราก็เก๋จะสอนให้เรียนก็
ไม่กินข้าวพอดีเขาครูเอ๋เดี๋ยวตอนที่จะ
โมโห
คู๋จะโอ้โหก็ว่ากูเอกต้องมีขนาด
ในการในคลิปหน้านะคะค่ะสวัสดีค่ะเจอกัน
ค่ะ
ก็สวัสดีค่ะพี่เรียนได้ไหมมีค่าบ๊ายบาย